Hello my fellow bean lovers, (did you just assume-) I'm sorry for making assumptions
But if you clicked on this video, I'm just going to assume that you're a fellow
passionate follower of the one and only BEANS
Our favorite hobbies is
Eating beans and watching Cars and trying to avoid ridicule.
Of course, there are haters (grrr) that doesn't (pewds I think you mean "don't" but okay) like beans
*pulls out a very detailed map of the world*
This is our plan of destruction, we will take over from this front
moving over to here
If you guys like beans, please go ahead and leave a like on this video right now
if you like bean so much, huh?
Why don't you go ahead and like this video, then
I bet you don't even like beans that much
I bet you don't even sleep with your beans. I bet you don't even eat beans while eating beans (I can't believe you pewds)
Pathetic. Well, I guess it's time for that to change (god has come)
Let's go through some inspo (inspiration) of THE BEANS
*new level of running out of ideas*
Want to thank whoever poured baked beans all over the slides at this park
and didn't clean it up
Very funny!
Have you done your part? Have you done your duty?
Have you been spreading beans across the world like this fellow, bean lover? I don't think so (Pewds is disappointed)
So don't even talk to me unless you put beans somewhere
That seemingly it wouldn't belong. I salute this bean sliding man or wahman
We accept anyone
A picture worth a thousand beans
Listen up. Listen up.
Unless you treat beans like the art form it is
Then we're not gonna get anywhere in this.
I just want to eat it, but I can't.
that's ART
We have to keep our guilty pleasure a secret. Sometimes hiding beans in our snacks
So people won't judge us well (too late Pewds)
Well- *laugh of relation*
I've done this myself while watching Cars 1 and 2 at the cinema.
First time. I was ridiculed
Second time. I came prepared
Life Hack came for free but of course, we don't only just
eat beans.
That's right everybody
We drink beans
And you know, why?
Because they have a lot of P R O T E I N in them.
Not s*y beans, you see these giant muscles? You see these?
(oH sTOp FLeXiNg pEWdS i aM sO jEAlOuS)
That's cuz of the protein in the beans
Oh my god. That is disgusting
That's what a level-one bean lover would say,
I however, am at least five ranks up in the bean-verse and this is a
Lovely dip to put your feet in
I would just love to slide it smoothly right into those Crocs ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Sliding to a woman's DM's-ahah.
No, thank you.
Sliding to a croc filled with beans. Ah- That's right a very good
What is this video? I'm trying to figure it out as I'm going.
Frequently bought together
Unless this says on your Amazon account.
Then you're just a fake fan (disgusting), a fake follower, a poser.
always
$19.99. That's a great- that's a great deal.
Excuse me, while I have a bite on this delicious Apple.
Oh That's right. You thought I was eating Apples?
Nah
NAH FAM
I'm eating beans.
There's always beans. If a bean disliker were to slice me in half right now
I wouldn't bleed. I would bleed beans
I wouldn't bleed blood, I would bleed beans. It's in my veins
It's in my system. It's in my DNA
I eat beans only n-words who eat beans can like this picture
That is me giving the video a thumbs up
Just like you should. If you like beans unless you're a faker daker
This man has so much beans in his body
That it's coming out of his eyes
and he has to keep them contained which I can respect 100%
Some say; This is the profit in the bean-mi-verse
some say he can see the future...
through the beans (so he's a bean Dr.Strange?)
Sometimes we just have to abandon
the beans
but rest assured we'll come back for the beans
Man, this is some...
These beans are fire
Nothing like some cold beans.
Sometimes you get distracted from what's important in life
Looking to renovate your home, well here's a cheap life hack for you.
Just crack open a can of beans
This sub brings me so much joy
Who needs money?
Everyone is talking about all these new currencies.
Bitconnect
BTC
but what does it really stands for?
That's right.
Beans
Times
Trumps
Coins
Beans Trump's Coins.
That's right. Everybody. We're.. I'll accept beans from now on instead of donations
Want your home to smell lovely and nice?
Bean up, baby. BEAN UP
*smells around*
Margaret, may I say, this house smells Wonderful!
Is is bEaNS?!
Here we have beans
inside of beans. That's hilarious.
Why are you still watching this video? It's all beans
(It's love, Pewds. Even if the vid's not that great)
How do you wash your clothes? That's right. Everybody with beans.
That's how I keep my white shirt so clean
Thanks to beans.
Arigaotu Bean-sama
Cupholder, is what a moron would use it for
Bean cup dispenser
Yeah~
Nothing like drinking some beans, everybody
Some classic Coca Cola flavored beans.
Oh my god, Jack. Now
I'm just getting annoyed. What did they- stop?
I mean, no. That looks great. That looks delicious
Pistachios. B-stichios. BEANSTACHIOS
Delicious. Delicious, everybody!
*pewds in disgust* What the hell stop
Abort! Abort!
Oh My God
Stop, please. Stop, please
Wonder what kind of games will launch?
Freshly squeezed beans, everybody. Wow.
*kiss* (magnifique)
Nothing, like a- nothing gets me going in the morning like some freshly squeezed beans.
oof
nothing to stop a child from being conceived
like shoving some beams up there
Up top, everybody! If you do it right now.
Nothing like some- well that's coffee beans
That doesn't count. Get out of here.
Nothing like some beans in the banana lamp.
What is wrong with me?
I think- think I'm losing it.
(Why are we still here?)
Nothing likes some beans to tell the time.
Oh my god
What's so great about beans is that if you spill your drink,
there's always more beans
*pewds refreshed*
Nothing quenches my thirst like a fresh can of beans with the boys.
Hmm, yummy
*family friendly words of encouragement*
(oh dear)
Are you kidding me?!
God dam it
It's not even Christmas
Unless you put beans in your Christmas ornament
It's not your birthday unless you get a bean birthday cake.
And it's not a summer without a bean ice cream
Beans is everything the essence of life.
How do you think the Germans lost the war?
*World War II flashbacks*
Because this is what they were fighting, (THE BEANS RETURN) They clearly stood no chance.
What do you think was in the a-bomb that hit in Hiroshima and Nagasaki?
That's right beans.
Beans'- just- everything
Man, that's a big bean...
You think I ran this joke to the death yet? (Yes. Good job. *clap  clap*)
Now, go forth my fellow bean lovers
You have been trained in the art of bean loving
Spread the word
Tell your friends and family to watch this video and tell them about the beans.
That's right.
If your friend send you this video,
that means they care for you.
That means they love you.
That means they want what's best for you. That's right
B E A N S
Now excuse me. I'm gonna have to go and find some more beans.
There's always beans to hunt.
I'm also creating a game called Bean-Bean Hunt *pewds with 300 IQ*
It's kind of like Pokemon go but with beans instead
I hope you guys will like that and as always, Bean Fist.
Thank you guys for watching.
BEANS
(What the heck was the point of this video.) (Probably to kill the meme.)
(Like seriously, Pewds) (Hush, child. He knows exactly what he's doing...I think)
A$$
(When beans didn't give you enough content so you have to show off a spicy game to get the video to the ten minute mark)
(Poor Brad and Brad 2)
(Press "F" in the comments for respect)
*God has left*
(This music is dope by the way)
(Seriously. Why are you still here?)
(Go)
(Are expecting Sam Jackson to pop in here)
(wearing a saucy leather number?)